Gladys Knights will be singing the
national anthem at the Super Bowl which
is a great choice I would have sung it
myself but why steal Tom Brady's thunder
of course thanks to a media whose
business model is conflict the anthem
controversy still lingers like a bad
odor it's one of those stories where you
can always begin a sentence with yet
there are some who are criticizing
Knight for accepting the honor whenever
I hear some I wonder who are they
some like multiple unknown forces it
seems like some is everywhere some say
this some say that some say reporters
without sources use some sadly we are
now at the mercy of some when there
aren't even any it's a make-believe
democracy how does Knight respond to
such criticism quote I pray that this
national anthem will bring us all
together in a way never before witnessed
and we can move forward and untangle
these truths untangle these truths which
mean so much to all of us she's saying
what we feel enough already
let's move on I'm with her she looks
great by the way amazing that is every
issue be it immigration climate or crime
the media desires only two positions in
the anthem case you're either for
standing during the anthem or against
police brutality when in fact 100
percent of the general population can
hold both positions gladys holds both
advocating for justice and the anthem so
I'm sure she will do a great job
probably even better than me even though
I'm sure some okay I look at her she is
not aged in like 40 years aging it's
incredible I know we got to ask her what
her secret is what if she says like
facials you know I I think one the good
news is she's doing the national anthem
the bad news maroon 5 is still playing
at halftime well I know you don't like
them I love Gladys Knight you know
midnight train all but I must say it's
so interesting this controversy someone
said if she wears a Colin Kaepernick
shirt they'll applaud her but but she's
having to apologize because there's so
many people I think especially why can
you say
what about colin kaepernick that's why
other artists refuse to participate
because they don't want to endorse the
idea of the NFL everything's normal
peer pressure against peer pressure I'm
tired of peer pressure like if if colin
kaepernick were given a job then they're
gonna find another reason to go after
her a person in the national anthem
maybe just give him a job for the rest
of season there you go you could have
tricked me I had no idea Jed is it I
like her messages
can we just unite and her idea is that
the the man theme is separate from the
social justice issues which Thoth makes
total sense and she has a long history
of fighting for social justice issues
for racial injustice which like just
needs research it's kind of sad though
that it's it's people are stunned that
she would say that the national anthem
could be used as a unifying force where
people the country's so removed from
that now and has made the national
anthem so divisive that for her to come
out and just say look you can be a
social justice warrior and sing the
national anthem and have this be a
unifying moment almost sounds far into
people that's kind of sad I think it
Jesse it's almost every segment or issue
that we talk about these days has to do
in its core an identity identity
politics it does and it never ends well
maybe this maybe this will finally be a
healing moment I hate to say healing
moment I was going to use another
analogy I think GLaDOS basically put the
last shovel of dirt on Kaepernick's
grave here's what the strange analogy is
over no one cares about Kaepernick
anymore no players even knelt barely at
all this year I mean it hasn't really
been a controversy as much this year at
all is it because it is show except for
the Eagles didn't go to the White House
but on the field players are not
kneeling anymore
Kaepernick is now what how many years
has he been out of the league he's never
coming back to the NFL and like you said
the only people making a big fuss about
this are a few people on Twitter GLaDOS
lads well respected social media warrior
like myself and it shot down all of
these people and repeated the talking
point that I've been using entire year
GLaDOS thanks for watching and listening
is that the anthem is a moment of
national
unity and that's where everybody should
come together and you can talk about
social justice afterwards I think there
are at least three moments in what you
said that upset like half of America
I don't know anybody wants to punch you